à redon d'arriver si tard moselle vient
pas de manière à témoin tous nous avons
dû libérer votre suite libéré ma suite
vous l'avait relâché dans la nature
il semble que vos notes ne nous est pas
été réglés
maman c'était biais d'un pacte whitman
celle ci ce sont les autres les aux
besoins nos foyers
leur mère 6 ha dont ils ont besoin
on va tout de même pas laisser la plus
grande star du monde sans rien à boire
frank sinatra et qui franck est génial
mais il n'est pas de rigueur landes
j'ai plus de maison même du mal à
trouver un abri de rien si tu portais à
londres tu serais grassement payés tu
veux dire qu'il faudrait que je quitte
mes enfants si je veux gagner
suffisamment d'argent pour élever mes
enfants
j'aimerais tellement rester quelqu'un
avec jodie il ya des centaines de gens
qui sont venus vous entendre chanter ma
bouche et toute cette chienlit jamais
écoutez moi je vous ai dit non ça va
bien c'est sûr que ça va aller à voir si
je serai le refaire
ouais devriez apprendre à faire
attention à vous vous n'entendez pas
nous avons tous notre part tout moment
et j'ai vu la nuit
[Applaudissements]
j'ai les mêmes rêves que la plupart des
gens juste plus de mal à les atteindre
[Musique]
vous faites quelque chose contre la
dépression j'ai fait quatre mariages peu
concluants
n'oubliez pas ce contenu
m
btb
[Musique]